hi everyone my name is marjan and i'm an
ai scientist working for polymerized
i'll give a quick introduction to myself
let me first introduce what we are going
to be talking about today which is how
to stack neural networks together right
so for everyone who's been into ml or ai
we've developed a lot of neural networks
we've worked with cnns dnns uh new age
technologies like graph neural networks
and stuff like that
but there is an application of neural
networks that really helps build a lot
of more ideas into the into the field
and that also helps us to combine powers
of different kinds of data sets into one
right so me i work as
a data scientist ai scientist machine
learning engineer at polymerize it's a
material science company based out of
singapore we are developing the next
generation ai platform to fuel the
growth of r d scientists across the
world
i'm a big big python fan i've previously
worked in a marketing ai platform
developed it from scratch where we
increased the rois by 1.5 1.6 x for all
our clients across the world
i have been corely involved in
explainable ai so explainable ai is
something that i'm really passionate
about because i really feel opening up
the black boxes are going to help us
understand the data and not just predict
with a higher accuracy which sometimes
is misleading
i've also
focused my areas of research into
tabular neural networks because neural
networks in terms of cnn they have a lot
of data there's a lot of content
available online and it's a lot like
copy paste but when it comes to deep
neural networks from tabular data
it becomes very essential because that
is that has a lot of applications in the
industry which might be missing right uh
reinforcement learning i've done quite
some work on reinforcement learning for
the supply chain domain to optimize for
costs times of delivery uh et cetera et
cetera and largely my current focus is
fully on optimization i'm going to be
giving you guys a bonus optimization
idea that i think will be really helpful
for all of you who've been building
models
and finally mlops is uh where i try to
make sure i learn every day because
until unless you can put your models in
production those models are practically
invaluable right uh let's move forward
so what is stacking when we talk about
stacking of models what we are trying to
understand is we are trying to get
multiple models together and use their
individual specific powers as one
right how does it help it helps by
decreasing your error variance right
suppose there's one model that performs
really well on a certain kind of data
set and there's another model that
performs really well on a certain kind
of data set you can consider an example
of outlier based data for example we
know random forest works really well
with outlier-based data sets
but it does linear regression does not
right but linear regression works really
well when the relationship between data
is linear
but random forest may not so in cases
where those situations can occur within
the data we can actually use the
capabilities of both the models to get a
higher accuracy or at least a comparable
accuracy with the best individual model
you have
whilst reducing the error variance to a
minimum we'll be seeing an example of
that soon
the second thing is it has to be
differentiated from bagging and boosting
based models right when we talk about
bagging a model like random forest so
every individual model which is a part
of the random forest is a tree
but when we talk about boosting models
then every next level model is dependent
historically on the previous model right
so how does stacking fundamentally
differentiate itself from bagging as
well as boosting models when we talk
about stacking it is different because
there are multiple independent models so
these models have no impact within each
other that separates it from boosting
which you can see and the second one is
where they are all heterogeneous they
can be different models which separates
itself from bagging so random forest has
multiple trees but a stacking model can
have different fundamental models linear
bayesian
decision trees etc etc right now coming
to the conclusion of why do we want to
stack neural networks together okay let
me give you an example
suppose we're going to be covering that
in a lot more detail today but
let's imagine a situation we want to
predict the price of a house now i know
all of you will be again the same data
again the same model we can go online
and just fetch everything ourselves
right but imagine a situation where you
have not just the features of the house
but you're also having the images of the
house which is easily fetchable right
when we're collecting data we can
collect images
right taking it a step further we can
also collect images about individual
parts of the house right we'll see an
example where we have the frontal view
the kitchen the bedroom and the bathroom
right essentially what we can figure out
are details from images that we might
not be directly getting from features
for example is there a crack in the
ceiling
right can you get that anywhere from any
features which is not an image it's very
tough right i mean even if there is the
data can be inaccurate the data can be
incomplete for a lot of houses and you
know how data is so we must ensure that
we have the capability of incorporating
different data sets
from different sources if need be and
then compiling them together and adding
them to a neural network that's what
we're going to do with stacking so what
kind of data sets do we have we can have
images we can have text data we can have
tabular data we can in fact have voice
data and we can combine the powers of
all of them with the individual networks
we know
right
how does it help it enhances the
capability by incorporating multiple
informative sources like we said each
model can be fine-tuned separately
or as well as they can be fine-tuned
together right you can combine and
hypertune or you can individually
hypertune and then combine those kind of
functionalities very easy with
tensorflow we'll be seeing that in the
example
now each of these models can
individually handle different data sets
right let's take for example
that you have a categorical data set and
you have a numerical data set
what we do is we combine the entire data
and build a single model or a deep
neural network with them but what
happens there is the categorical data
needs to be labeled or binarized and
then it gets passed so the size of the
network increases in the first layer and
it has to be eventually
passed on to the eventual layers of the
model itself but what if we could make a
separate neural network for numerical
data and a separate neural network for
categorical data and then those two
models can be stacked together to make a
prediction it will actually help us
reverse engineer the importance of the
features with explainable ai
otherwise explainable ai and a lot of
these algorithms that we've heard of
let's say integrated gradients or deep
lift or shaft all the popular algorithms
that help in explainable ai they are
sometimes not very well working with the
sparsity or high sparsity in the data
set so we can separate them and
individually explain the values that
makes a lot of sense
and also we can finally use that for
transfer learning so you have vgg g16
densenet resonate all the popular models
trained on the imagenet data set with a
great deal of better performances we can
just make their last layer
removed and we can also set them to not
be trained and just use them as a
dimensionality reduction technique to
get the best features out of our images
by using the top end models that
researchers and developers have built
right
an example that you see the image here
is of the different models you can see
linear regression you can see k n you
can see cart you can see svm base and
stacking what you'll notice here is
stacking might not be always the best
performing model but it will always have
a less error variance
as you can see the size is always lesser
so you are more likely to not have a
very randomly or abruptly performing
model these models will be robust to the
situation so in a high pressure
situation in a very risky situation
where models have to be built you can
use stacking to make sure the error
variance is low
right any questions so far
yeah
okay
so on the y-axis you have the error
right the errors are basically plotted
in the box plot
the box plot the box plot center is the
mean then there's the quartile three
quartile one
right quad inter quantity interquartile
range minus 1.5 times that one so if you
see
cart is the model or let's let's
consider linear regression right
so the error
if you see 0.8 to 0.94 something
so there the size of the error is very
high they can be very low
these are different models
okay so this one is linear regression on
the absolute left
lr then there's knn and this card the
support vector machine there's bayesian
regression to stacking
okay any other questions
okay
right so what are we going to be
building today in this tutorial we're
going to first give a quick example of
stacking classical ml models this will
be a quick uh just i'll be showing the
code i'll be looking at the results and
we'll be sharing if there are any
thoughts the next what we are going to
do is we are going to stack two deep
neural nets together and we are going to
be talking about the fundamental
decisions that we are supposed to make
for example
do we train the last layer do we have
multiple final layers what should be the
sizes
right and all the other critical details
will come up and finally we are going to
be training a stacking dnn which will
have a numerical network a categorical
network and four cnn stacked together
i know the image might not be very clear
but it's a pretty complicated network to
work with but it'll make sense when it
comes up
right so the stacking classical ml model
will work just like this model that you
see here there'll be an input a copy of
that input will be passed to each of the
three base models which is the first
layer and the output of the base models
will be learned by a final meta model it
will also be trained in the process and
you will have the final output
all right we're going to use
scikit-learn obviously with the ensembl
ensemble module and we get stacking
regression and stacking classifier it's
pretty easy we'll just quickly see in a
minute okay so let's head over to the
code
i i hope everyone's able to get the
tutorial slack link so you can open my
github profile and we can go to the
first notebook which says classical ml
stacking
i also learned something interesting
from github.com you can just do github
and then try to collab
and it automatically switches into a
google collab sheet
right i'll be connecting
yeah sure
sorry one second
oh it doesn't work that way
github.com
datagasmic
yeah sorry there was a question
uh no we'll have to install them but
most of them are already there with
google collab so we don't have to work
there's going to be one library that
we're going to use in hyper parameter
tuning stack networks
there we'll need to install a library
specifically
at the runtime
okay
so we import the basic libraries for ml
anyone who's ever built a machine
learning model they definitely know
pandas numpy train test split linear
regression k neighbors regressor
decision tree regressor support vector
regressor and from the scikit-learn
ensemble we get stacking regressor and
from the metrics we quickly pick a mean
squared error right the metric can be of
your choice what's important is how it
is related to the other models
individually and as a stack
right i'm going to be picking the
california housing data set because it's
available with scikit-learn it's going
to be pretty quick sorry
yeah uh after github you have to type to
collab
github.2collab.com
not.2collab github twocollab.com
okay we have our input and output
separated with housing data housing
target
and we also do a train test split
now comes uh the first section which is
the individual models right here what
the process we're going to be following
is we're going to train individual
models observe their performances
observe their error variances which you
can see printed on my screen i'll just
quickly run the cells and make sure
everything's working fine
so these three initial models that i
took support vector regressor k
neighbors regressor and decision tree
regressor
i quickly run a loop to fit it on the
training data and predict it on the test
data and there's a small print statement
that prints root mean square error and
the error variance with np.var
just quickly scroll my screen to the
right so if you can see
right let me run this cell
i joined the conference last minute so
please pardon that i did not put it in a
data frame so it can be represented
nicely i just made a print statement as
soon as i could
it's because of the support vector
regressor that it might take some more
time support vector regressors are nasty
in terms of taking more time
okay
so right now the best performing model
is decision tree regressor with 0.72
root mean squared error
and it also has the minimum variance of
0.309
right
now a requirement of the stacking
regressor from scikit-learn ensemble is
that you need to have a list of tuples
where the first element of the tuple is
the name of the model so it's uniquely
identified and the second is the actual
model
so i've just done name of the model
comma i for individual models so that
will give me a list of tuples where each
element in the tuple would be the name
of the model and the model itself
and then the second part which is the
meta model which is the model that's
going to be taking output from
individual models and then be learning
from the next steps
right
and finally we have the stacking
regressor so you can see stacking
regressor has estimators which is the
base layer final estimators which is the
minor uh meta model and cv cv equals
three is integrated in scikit-learn so
it's a cross-validation yep
sorry please repeat your question
uh i am not sure but they'll definitely
be an opportunity
uh it has n jobs equals minus one so
it's doing distributed training for sure
we can use task as well i think yeah
yes one very important question here
that we need to address is pass through
equals false
right past three equals false is very
important because it tells you if
at the time of training this model
are you are you going to be training all
of them together or are you going to be
training them individually so if you
said pass through equals true is going
to take the input data and it's going to
train all the individual models together
right but if pass through is false then
the individual models that will be
trained will remain the same
and you are only going to be training
the meta model individually right so it
is going to combine the outputs of the
base models
let's say it's a linear regression
equation ax1 plus bx2 plus cx3 so it's
going to be learning a b and c for x1 x2
and x3 in different data sets
right
n jobs minus 1 is for distributed model
training
and we run it
simple fit x train y train
predict
looking at the mean square error and
looking at the variance here
i would set pass through to true in
cases where i do not want the meta model
to be very biased what happens is
sometimes let's say a decision tree
regression model is working really well
so if i have the meta model and with the
pass through equals false then it will
largely be taking the decision tree
model
right but if i have comparative models i
would uh i would rather do pass through
equals false but if i have
non-comparative models let's say the
data has a drift
in those cases i will be doing pass
through equals true so it knows for
every instance which model performs
really well
okay so we have the best performance in
terms of lowest error 0.67 if you go and
compare it was 0.72 here for decision
tree as well as the error variance which
was earlier 0.309 which was the minimum
we now have an error variance of 0.23
i hope this slide and the code is clear
if there are any questions happy to take
them
yes
okay so this is done
now let's talk about the fundamental
questions ideas and decisions that we
need to take when we stack a neural
network okay so the first question data
based model selection
do you want different models
of different designs
or do you want different models of
different types let's say you want a
deep neural network and a convolutional
neural network
or do you want two deep neural networks
to work simultaneously right a lot of
times what we've done at polymerize is
uh we've created a very long uh
network and we've also created a very uh
tall network in terms of their designs
and we've tried to understand in a lot
of cases where the width sometimes
performs better and sometimes the length
performs better so the bias in the data
let's say you have some kind of outliers
in a particular set of variables in in
some data set so a larger model works
really better with outliers but with
non-outliers the taller model works so
we've sometimes combined two different
design systems in a neural network and
have made it work
the second question we need to ask is do
we have different data sources right
first of all can you collect different
data sources that's obviously a question
we need to answer first but if you are
able to collect different data sources
how do you stack them right i'll give
you an example of graph neural network
that will make it a lot clearer because
sometimes the networks need an embedding
layer uh the sizes of data are different
just giving an example let's say for for
my domain in material sciences let's say
you have five ingredients in a
formulation in a chemical reaction and
in another experiment you have just four
right so if you collect the structural
property relationship of each of these
ingredients
at one iteration you have five structure
property relationships and in another
iteration you have just four right so in
cases like those we create uh embedding
layers just to make sure that the final
layer sizes match with the next steps
right the second question is the
training process do you want to train
the networks individually first tune
them to their best capabilities and then
stack them or do you want the models to
learn together combined right and
obviously there's the third case where
certain models are individually trained
and certain models are trained in a
combined way let's say the dnn and the
cnn can be trained together and we can
also use a pre-trained model on the
image data set right so that decision is
also something we consider
the final layer do you want the final
layer to be directly coming from the
stack networks or do you want an
additional dense layer before the output
layer and the stagna networks right for
example if you have a huge stack
right you cannot directly have a single
output for all the 20 or 30 or 40 nodes
that you will have in your stacked
output so we'll also need a dense layer
to be connected with the stacked output
and then have the final node that makes
a prediction we'll see that in the
tutorial example
uh hyper parameter tuning again very
important do we hyper parameter tune the
entire stacked model or do we hyper
parameter tune only uh singularly and
then combined
and finally pre-trained models do you
want to train pre-trained models uh
let's say you can just set trainable
equals to false for any pre-trained
model you have or you can also train
just the last layer you can individually
selectively uh deny the training of
certain layers of the pre-trained model
that's also possible with tensorflow
layers
okay so we're going to be building this
okay the first network has its set of
properties and characteristics the
second network has its own set of
properties and dimensions and then we
have this final layer which you can see
as the concatenated layer right the
concatenate layer is where we're going
to be focusing and trying to find out
how to build that entire section how to
connect them together and then we have
the final dense layer which is going to
be the prediction output layer
okay so we build network one we build
network two
then using the keras layers dot
concatenate we concatenate the output of
the two networks
and then we finally create a dense layer
which is going to be
using the functional api of tensorflow
we are going to be combining the input
of the two individual layers okay and
another key aspect of this is we need to
also apply the same dimensions
while predicting which we are while
building the model for example the input
of the first network and the input of
the second network
they can be the same they can be
separate so while making a prediction
we'll have to ensure we pass to
tensorflow the input that goes to the
first model and the input that goes to
the second model
right any questions or we'll move to the
code
okay
right so
i've just imported all the essential
libraries that i'm going to be needing
throughout
quickly running this
fetching the california housing data set
now this data set has two additional
parameters latitude and longitude
uh a lot of times latitude and longitude
are used to derive certain kind of
properties for example mobility
can be derived by using the latitude and
longitude and
there was a company presenting earlier
mobile wallet team they do this with
your latitude and longitude they
actually give you the mobility
statistics so you can actually convert
latitude and longitude to get the
mobility or you can use them in terms of
numerical data with respect to how far
how left or how right it is how top or
how bottom it is so we look at that
if you do not want to train on latitude
and longitude just attaching this
indexing would work
okay uh in the train test split uh
please observe that i've added a random
state
okay random state is for repeatability
of results definitely but when we are
stacking two neural networks we have to
make sure that the training data goes
the same training data goes to both the
networks at the same time otherwise the
output would be something else
and one one network would be trained on
some data the other will be trained on
some data so they'll never be able to
reach the target
right so random state important
right building the first network
again simply building a neural network
sequential
adding one dense layer sorry there's the
question
okay
so adding uh four dense layers the final
one is
the four units layer now observe closely
that i did not make a final prediction
on this i did not make the final layer
to be one and also i did not compile the
model
i did not compile the model because this
is not where the network one compiles
the networks what network one's output
is going to go to the stacked uh model
and it's going to be compiled in the
final stack model so we are not going to
compile the network one
i'm just going to create the network one
right we'll quickly check out the
summary
right nothing nothing new nothing
strange nothing fancy
network two i've changed the dimensions
a little bit so now there are just two
hidden layers with 16 nodes each
and again i do not compile the network
two
now this is the crucial step this is
where we start stacking okay
combined input is equal to the
concatenation layer from tensorflow
right this is where the real game is
happening
network one dot output and network two
dot output right so the list
has two elements two models are getting
stacked network one output network two
output
and the combined input layer which is
the concatenated layer
it gets passed on via the tensorflow
functional api
to the next dense layer
which has final node one activation
linear right and this is where we have
compiled the two networks
with a final dense layer which is going
to give us the output and finally we are
also going to be using the model
module
where the inputs will be network one dot
input network two dot input and the
outputs will be x right
now just looking at this
i think it makes sense that no matter
what model we have
everything is just now another comma
separated value in both the lists in the
concatenated layer and in the model sub
module
right you can add as many modules as you
want you can add sorry you can add as
many models as you want and you can
concatenate as as much as you want and
then you can just use the final model
building api to get the inputs and the
output
right
once you're done executing this i'm
sorry not run the cell above
once you're done with this
quickly check the model summary
right you see there's a concatenation
layer here
right
sorry
same input layer yes we're going to be
passing the same input data to all of
them
so the input layer does not get
transported to both the networks the
input layouts for both of them are
separate
but the data is going to be the same
okay so this is my network
one of them starts here
they get concatenated here
and i have the dense layer which has
one node in the output
right i'm going to be using adam
and compile this stacked model
then i'm going to fit it
when fitting the x has to be passed
the x train data has to be passed
multiple times because the two models
are going to be taking as input you can
actually relate this
to this
right the inputs coming for the model
will be coming from both x trains
and we take certain set of epochs and
batch size pardon me i am not going to
be training this for a lot of epochs and
showing you the results because that's
not relevant for the talk
but i just want to show that it works
and the error is significantly reducing
and while making a prediction
again i have to pass x test in a list
for both the networks to work
finally we can check the performance
also an interesting fact is that i can
access
the network one network two and the
model separately now why is this
essential let's say i want to understand
and explain the network one individually
right let's say network one is a
convolutional neural network
right so i would like to observe the
important parts of the picture of the
image separately and i would want to
know the importance of numerical
features that my neural deep neural
network is trained on separately
right so because i can access individual
networks from this stack layer i will
also be able to explain them either
layer-wise or node-wise towards the
output and how they contribute to the
entire model
okay it will also give us a sense let's
say you want to decide if you want to
buy the image data of the house a lot of
people a lot of companies are buying
data sets from these big data management
platforms right this is an entirely new
area so you can also negotiate on the
quality of data that you are getting so
let's say in making a prediction 30 to
40 percent of importance is coming from
a particular vendor who's providing the
image
right and from another vendor you are
getting 50 to 60 importance of the final
prediction so i would choose which
vendor to when i am doing the
explanation
right so that was the fundamental idea
the concatenate layer the functional api
as well as the final model that i can
build with tensorflow layers
coming back to the slides
now let's look at a really yeah sorry
okay so what i was saying is let's say
you have a convolutional neural network
which is going to predict using the
images and you have a deep neural
network which is going to predict using
the numerical features that you've got
right
in that situation how much of the
prediction is getting impacted by the
image data and how much of the
prediction is coming from the numerical
data to understand if images are more
valuable or the numerical data is more
valuable for example if you take a house
number of bedrooms number of bathrooms
the the one the example that you can see
area of the house these three features
they'll be common across a lot of houses
right but the image is going to separate
uh the quality of the house
when you compare with bedrooms or you
know area etc etc the zip code obviously
it is a categorical feature so zip code
will be deal separately we'll be we're
going to be building a categorical
neural network for the same and finally
the price is the target column i hope
that makes sense
uh i don't think we'll have time for
that but i'd
i'd sometimes love to talk about the
explainability part of it
i have spent around six months doing
that yeah
yeah uh if they're missing we'll not be
able to deal with that we'll have to
ensure that all the data is available
when we're making a prediction so for
one house you're going to need the four
images and you're going to need the data
row as well
uh if one of them is missing it might be
a problem but we might default we might
set some default for some missing values
we can take averages and fill the
missing values just to make sure that
the other parts of the house
might for example let's say a house does
not have
a pool right a swimming pool let's say
we have swimming pool images a house
does not have a swimming pool right in
those cases we'll have to find ways to
manage them we can actually have empty
images as well we can just concatenate
you know white images that's fine
okay so we're going to be talking about
this example the link to the research
paper where i found the data set is
there uh the link to the github where i
found the data set is also there
uh it's an amazing paper i would uh want
everyone to give it a read whenever you
get time
but practically this is the data set in
front of you right
in the houses data set that we're going
to be cloning from github we have for
every house
four images we have a bathroom image a
bedroom image a frontal view image and a
kitchen image right and this is for all
the 535
uh images that we have
and for each of the houses we have their
numerical features which is number of
bedrooms number of bathrooms area of the
house zip code and its price right so
what we are going to be doing is we are
going to be building a separate network
for the numerical data
a separate network for the categorical
data which is obviously the zip code and
we're going to be building on individual
convolutional neural networks for the
four sections of the house images for
which we already have right so let's
move to the code
we're going to be building this
first we're going to prepare the data
obviously the data is not available
exactly the way we want so we're going
to have to work with it uh neural
network with numerical data categorical
data we have to binarize the categorical
data
convolutional neural networks
concatenate all of them together add a
dense layer post concatenation so this
is why i was saying that an important
decision in stacking is are you going to
add a layer between the final output
layer
and the concatenated layer
a lot of times when there is a lot of
stacking we need to ensure that there's
another layer that knows the importances
of individual models but if there are
simple stacks two or three neural
networks which are mostly similar
getting past the same data then you can
directly have them in the final output
layer
and this is what we're going to be
building let's quickly see that in code
okay any questions so far
okay cool
i have all the dependencies i want
pandas numpy cv2 is for images
io is for im read which is to read the
images into numpy arrays glob is for
accessing the files that i'm going to be
cloning into my drive label binarizer is
for helping with the categorical data
train test split for the model i have
tensorflow sequential model flattening
it dense batch normalization conf 2d max
pooling activation dropout so on and so
forth i also have the layers and models
adam plot model
okay
now this is the step which will help us
get the data set let's quickly run this
it's going to download
data set
for me it's there because it's just
reconnected my kernel
and here is the data set
uh the folder is large so you might have
to double click on this
and you see this
so you have
four images of the house hundred
four images of the house 101 and so on
and so forth for all the 535 houses that
we have
they also have
a
housesinfo.txt file inside this folder
the houses dataset which will give you
access to bedrooms bathrooms area zip
code and price
to sort them in order i had to write
this small piece of code
which takes the root path and generates
them in order because if you sort python
has that 0 1
and one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten so after one comes one
zero and not two so to help with that i
had to create this small amount of code
it's going to get bathrooms as a list
all the file names in order one two
three till 535
and it's going to do the same for
bedrooms kitchens and frontals
right this is the name of the text file
you'll find it in the folder
the columns were not mentioned directly
so i had to write them from the
documentation i read
and this is my data frame
i do a quick check
by the way for the question you were
asking i do a quick check for any is
nulls
and the shape of the bathrooms kitchens
bedrooms and frontals just to make sure
that i don't have anything missing
because that will not let the code work
the way it should
okay so i have the three columns for
numerical columns which is bedrooms
right
bathrooms in area which are these first
three columns
right i have zip code for the
categorical columns here
now following the steps we discussed in
the slide
the first is the numerical dnn
starting with sequential adding a dense
layer input dimensions coming from the
numerical columns of the data frame
uh the ending units to be eight a hidden
layer then dense units eight again and
finally it is going to return two nodes
in the final layer of the first network
processing the categorical data
initializing the label binarizer doing
the dot fit transform
on the categorical data
it's going to
completely burst open the data set for
zip codes number of unique zip codes
will become the number of columns after
binarizing these labels i hope there's
no confusion with that
let's run this cell as well
categorical dnn created again not a lot
of uh effort put into number of nodes or
number of layers it's just for the sake
of explanation of how to stack we can
definitely try and hyper parameter tune
them i'll give you an example with ray
tune one of the distributed hyper
parameter tuning frameworks yeah
yeah that's why we're not going to do a
great search we're going to do bayesian
optimization with hyperopt and ray tune
which is a distributed framework it can
use gpus and you can initialize as many
model trainings together i mean the
number of processors you have is equal
to the number of models you can train at
a time we'll see an example the notebook
hyper parameter tuning stack regressors
it has all the code and yes you're
correct the hyper parameter space is
going to be huge but i have the added
advantage of hyper parameter tuning each
aspect of each of the models so i can
you know use different kernel
initializers for different models for
categorical data the kernel initializer
might be different for numerical data
the kernel initializer might be
different so we have the ability we'll
be just coming to that in a minute
okay
so categorical dnn created
now each of the data sets from bathrooms
bedrooms kitchens
as well as frontals they've been
converted the images have been resized
to a common shape and the numpy areas
have been concatenated to individual
lists
converting all of them into arrays to be
directly used
y is obviously the price column which is
fairly simple right
now coming to this segment again
lots of code but mostly copy paste and
edit i again apologize for such nasty
code in front of all the python stars
here but again last minute
apologize
uh bat train images bar test images y
train and y test again with train test
split bathrooms data y train size set to
0.8 and please do not forget random
state 42 for all of them otherwise
you'll be using different data sets and
different outputs for all the models
which will not make
sense you have the same for the bed same
for the kitchen same for the front right
and the last two lines are for numerical
and categorical
okay so i have the training data set
matched in order for all the six models
that i'm going to be training
and i'm going to be using the same test
for them
any questions
okay image data sets need to be
processed they need to be scaled with
255 just to have values between zero and
one so that's just it
okay because i had to create four
convolutional neural networks i did
something simple i created a function
that will return a convolutional neural
network and i can just directly create
four cnns
i have a convolutional layer max pooling
again a convolutional max pooling again
finally a convolution and a flattened
layer
finally the dense layer which is going
to give me the output of the network
and i create four cnns
now
back to square one
concatenate
numerical dnn dot output categorical dna
dot output bathroom model dot output
bedroom model dot output kitchen and
frontal right so i combined the output
of all the individual neural networks i
have
into one layer which is the
concatenation layer
post the concatenation layer i will now
have a dense layer which has six nodes
this is what we were talking about
earlier when you want to add another
layer between the concatenation layer
and the final output this is where we do
it again using the functional api the
combined output gets passed to the dense
layer that we create and the final layer
has again a dense layer with one node
and functional api gets x into the final
layer
finally i'm using the model
in tensorflow the inputs are defined
just like i defined the concatenation
layer
and the outputs is my final layer which
i just created here
right
i run this
my neural network is ready my stag
neural network is ready
optimization with adam and model compile
and plot model
looks very complicated but we all know
what we did we have four cnns one
numerical dnn one categorical dna
okay
now fitting the model again the the only
thing that changes is the input to the
model
because the input will be again in the
same order numerical categorical and all
the four images y will obviously be
white train
i'm running it for a small number of
epochs and a small batch size
just to prove that it works seamlessly
without any kind of issues and the error
decreases at every epoch
okay
we can skip that
prediction again model.predict the input
that goes into the prediction is going
to be the test of the numerical data the
categorical data and the image data
together
right and then we can simply do a dot
predict
and it works perfectly
and then obviously we can store the
predictions into a list and compare the
percentage error mean squared error
things like that any questions
that's a great question so the way it
works is
i have observed that when you stack
all the models together and you do the
hyper parameter tuning you're actually
hyper parameter tuning like like
the man said that it increases hugely
but individual models can be trained on
separate machines and then they can be
combined the only thing that you need to
make sure that is the final layer that
you have i mean you have to set
everything to trainable equals false and
only the concatenation layer has to be
trained so it only learns how to predict
combining the individual models and not
all the biases and values i mean weights
and biases from all the entire model
right so that's a way to increase
distributed computing
but uh stacking models together and
training them also works if the model is
simple if the model is easier
yeah
there's no advantage my experience
personally has been that if you add more
layers because you're already
concatenating and then you're taking a
layer
there's not much deeper information
available to add i mean we should be
adding layers in the convolutional
networks or the individual models and
not after the concatenation because they
can individually predict the price of a
house based on the frontal view let's
say right but post what it has already
achieved there's not a lot to achieve
there
okay
so we did this
awesome
other ideas and applications before
moving to hyper parameter tuning i just
want to give you guys a quick heads up
on what are the possibilities of this
learning that we just had
so for material sciences when i work at
polymerize we started out by
understanding that there's a lot of
small data sets right just 25
experiments 30 experiments or 40
experiments right because experiments
take like weeks and they're expensive so
companies cannot afford having like
millions of experiments done until
unless it's a simulation environment
so uh when we started out we understood
that every let's say take take for an
example it's an experiment it has
ingredients let's say different
compounds nacl
uh sodium sulfate etc etc then you have
processing conditions what was the
temperature what was the humidity uh
what was the
let's say other factors of what was the
rotation rpm of the motor you used how
fast are you mixing them what is the
speed of adding certain ingredient in
the entire compound and then you have
multiple properties there's properties
like heat sensitivity compression
elongation all of those individual
properties
so you can imagine the width of the data
is pretty huge
right and largely the network the data
is sparse because you're not going to be
using every ingredient in every
formulation
and there are a lot of cases when
ingredients are usually replacements of
other for example carbon a in one of the
experiments carbon b in another of the
experiments so that creates a lot of
sparsity because you have ten different
variations of carbon and in each
formulation you will only be using one
so if there are ten experiments that you
do
every
row has only one value for a particular
carbon and all the other carbons are
zero just to make it a valid network and
a valid data set
so the width is huge but the length is
small right so what do we do we add
additional functionalities and we get
some data set by scientific literature
right and experiential learning so what
do we do we find out these chemical
compounds we try to get their entropy uh
their rotation their bonds how many
double bonds how many single bonds to
add that additional valuable information
right inside the formulation and then
what we started to realize is the
structural property of individual
chemicals that are going to be part of
the form formulation add a lot of value
right just take for an example you know
coming from india we were in standard 10
11 and 12 here i think they might call
it high school or something else so when
you add two compounds together not only
the compounds but their direction should
also match because if the directions are
different some other compound might be
created and the direction is reversed
some other compounds are created right
so the structural property relationship
is also a very important factor that we
should consider so there are a lot of
libraries that can actually convert
they have the intelligence of converting
your chemical name into the chemical
structure right and then you have these
chemical structure images that you can
use a cnn with
and predict when you actually are
combining different formulations right
so we built this entire platform we also
use a technology called neo4j which is a
knowledge graph you can actually store
these chemicals in a graphical format
and then we use graph neural networks
which is pretty exciting it's something
that i think everyone should learn about
once we have that now we have a network
of the experiments that we have the
actual data
then we also want to know what is the
importance of the derived data you know
the fetching of elongation property uh
sorry entropy the bonds the donors
different data sets that we've derived
okay and finally the images so now we
have three different neural networks and
they're all going to be contributing to
predict the property
of the final compound so this is an
interesting application where we can use
stack neural networks the second one is
customer retention you can see there's a
feedback text that comes from the
customer there's an audio call as well
that the customer and the customer
service executive might have had so that
data is also available we can combine
those also as well as the ratings given
by the customers on different products
or the purchases that the customers have
made in the past and you can combine all
of that data together build a stack
neural network and predict if the
customer is going to stay or not any
questions
because there are so many models
okay
so what what i have done largely is
we've we have an internal tool which
does a model validation in checking
right so there's digits con conditions
that we apply a lot of mathematical and
statistical factors like for example if
i pass zeros as a row
right in the experiment state if i pass
zero and it's still giving me a property
of elongation as 500 right that does not
make sense so that is a validation
factor that we apply and overfitting yes
i mean we look at tensorboard all the
curves and the different ways to check
model properties but there's a lot of
logical validations that we need to do i
mean
there's statistical validations that can
be easily printed on a report but you
need to analyze it but there's a lot of
logical validations that need to be done
because when a client is using it he
doesn't want to see you know something
that appears out of nowhere so
robustness is definitely a challenge
yes
so we usually go about five to ten
percent of missing data and encoding i
mean how you handle missing values right
if you have fifty percent missing values
it will not make sense but if you have
like five or ten percent that works
because a lot of cases we can generalize
suppose the customer did not give a
rating
so it's a zero rating right i mean
that's how we can generalize if the
customer did not write a text
right so
they didn't even want to give you a
feedback i mean that's how bad a service
they've experienced so we handle those
situations that way
large largely logical but uh
mathematically we try to use some amount
of missing value additions
anna yeah any other questions yeah
um
[Music]
sure so the way it works is we can
define our own class of making a dot
predict
right i mean neural networks have a dot
predict
as well as the classical machine
learning models also have a dot predict
we just need to define a function that
can handle that dot predict in the class
that we are aggregating different
families of networks
but if you don't have the same
assumptions and models yeah
what are the kind of problems that you
right so when the assumptions are not
same the way it works is one particular
model performs really bad the other one
performs really well and they at least
balance out the impact such that your
accuracy is not absolutely poor your
accuracy is not absolutely high
and the error will be there obviously
but that error will balance each other
that's why using heterogeneous models
works because if the relationship is not
linear and you're using a linear
regression model it's obviously going to
give you something not very relevant but
if there is a random forest if there's
another model supporting it then it
might guide towards that situation and
when we do the pass-through equals true
or false situation it's uh the model
also learns for what kind of data do you
want to prioritize random forest for
what kind of data you want to prioritize
linear regression and that's what we've
seen in explainability as well based on
a particular data point you will be
seeing that a lot of importance has been
given to a particular model and when
that bias occurs that it's always
favoring random forest that's when we
try to you know make certain kind of
changes
okay another interesting application
could be marketing uh let's say you are
spending a lot of dollars on facebook
google different kinds of channels
because i worked in the marketing
industry so i have a real-time
experience of doing that but also about
the image or the poster or the way you
represent the marketing advertisement
that also adds a lot of value the text
that you put in your marketing
advertisement that also adds a value so
there is nlp convolutional neural
network and deep neural network combined
and that really helps in marketing
because you might be spending a hundred
thousand dollars
on marketing with facebook but if the
text you've written on facebook is not
catchy enough then that hundred thousand
dollars will not add as much value as a
good catchy title with fifty thousand
investment right that's the conversion
ratio aspect because facebook has a
conversion ratio for converting clients
but the ad itself might have a high
quality of conversion or low quality of
conversion i hope that makes sense
okay so hyper parameter tuning stack
models uh this will involve a lot of
code i am uh sorry for that again i
should have built it better
i actually got my visa on the last day
of which i had to book a ticket so
there's no way uh jim here at pi data
was really struggling with me i had
around like 30 to 40 emails telling him
yeah i've applied for the visa they're
not doing this i'm trying this i'm
trying that so finally it arrived and
glad to be in london
okay uh so for hyper parameter tuning uh
very very important very very
complicated but easily understood let's
do this
ray is the library that we need to work
with
all of you will have to install ray it
does not come installed
with google collab just like tensorflow
and other libraries are
ray is an upcoming distributed training
platform i've used it it works like
magic to be very honest once you've
compiled the code once everything works
seamlessly
it can work in a 16 core system in a 32
core system and it really saves us a lot
of time when building like 500 or 600
models individually
okay
so
data fetch and processing
for the stacked models we have all the
libraries and dependencies we need
distributed training
i don't want to go into the individual
aspects and how they work but
for ray tuner these are all that help
you in bayesian optimization to simulate
better parameters for your model
uh there's concurrency limitation
there's hyper opt search which is the
bayesian optimization
hyperband scheduler how to schedule
different models and integrate them with
the threads
and a tuned report callback which helps
ray understand if the simulation it did
is increasing the performance or
decreasing the performance of the model
hyper opt for optimization and the
metrics
okay
not complicating it further with adding
more data sets using the same data set
train test split
okay
now this is a crucial part
where individual model
possible hyper parameters
can be designed
for a neural network there is a certain
kind of hyper parameters that you would
need for a convolutional network there
are certain kind of parameters do you
need and with nlp you'll need something
else so based on the experience of
machine learning engineers or ai
engineers you can design the hyper
parameter space so that the tuning does
not take a lot of time for example you
can see in the first network i've used
glorot uniform and he normal which are
the kernel initializers
uh the biases that i've used is ones and
glory uniform again for the second
network i've used glorut normal and he
uniform right so i can actually design
different hyper parameters and these
designs can also happen at a
model level at a layer level as well for
example you want to initialize biases
and variance weights for every
individual layer you can do that you can
see that in the example the only thing
that you will have to remember is these
names should be unique otherwise they'll
be used as a duplicate label it actually
works with a named tuple kind of
situation so it cannot have a similar
name for multiple aspects of it
i've added dropout i've also added a
batch normalization tuner which is going
to tell me if a batch normalization
layer is useful or not
and finally for the stacked model
finally i have the learning rate i have
the epochs and i have the batch size
right so this is my design space
okay
hyper tuner
this hyper tuner is going to first build
network one
sequential dense activation
bias initializers kernel initializers
and i have linked them to the search
space uh keys that we originally had
it also has the second layer with the
different bias and kernel initializers
that you can see which is again gives us
the freedom of designing our networks
and each layer of our network
dropout layer another dense layer
another dense layer for network one
because we're going to concatenate it
network two similar procedure followed
kernel initializers bias initializers
for a first layer
batch normalization if it is true there
will be a batch normalization layer
otherwise there won't be one
and network two will have the final 16
layers and again this will not have the
final single node because we are going
to concatenate it
stacking the networks together
concatenate network one output network
two output we've seen that fundamental
idea
functional api combined input again
model creation with inputs of network
one dot input network two dot input and
output to bx which i've just created by
using the functional api
adam as the optimizer compiling this
model.fit obviously i have to pass both
the training data sets here
i'm fetching the epochs from the space
batch size from the space
and additionally i am adding a callback
here this is very important because if
there is no callback of the error ray
tune will not know if it's moving
towards the right direction or not
so this entire function that we just
created which is the tuner function
right this does not return the model
it just has a callback from raytune
integration that will tell us the mean
squared error and raytune will know in
which direction to improve the
simulations
right uh for example if it's really
performing well with a glorot uniform
initializer it's going to make sure that
it fixes the glory uniform and changes
other aspects
i did not complicate this further for
you because we can actually have
dynamic number of layers in each network
and we can also have dynamic nodes in
each network doing that search parameter
tuning right i mean the four the four uh
the 16 here they can also be coming from
the hyper parameter tuner space but
that's going to take a lot of time to
train and we're going to need gpus
i've worked with that so i don't want
you guys to go through the pain
okay this is another function which is
simply a copy and paste right there's
not a lot of changes except one
which is
this function does not have a callback
in the compilation because ray tuner no
longer needs it once ray tuner has got
the best set of hyper parameters we can
use those best hyper parameters to tune
to train another model and that will be
our final model
it also has the history if you want to
integrate it with tensorboard or if you
want to plot the errors for accuracy
that works fine
and we return the history in the model
this function is also done
finally the tune dnn
this is where a lot of
computational experience comes into play
so you can see this is very important
resources per trial
suppose you have a 16 core cpu
so you can actually dynamically have as
many instances created and that many
models can be parallelly trained and
tuned with raytune
number of samples this is where you add
how many models do you want to train
we've done with 1 000 2000 models and
you can just if 2000 models and 16
processors are used it does not take a
lot of time and if you add gpus
boom
the tuned dnn function here that we see
takes the best configuration so the
analysis that tune dot run gives as a
return
that analysis has the best config
attribute the best config attribute is
the finally hyper final hyper parameter
tuned space right so you will get for
each layer for each uh aspect what is
the best parameter that you want
just want to ignore warnings here
and that's it with tuned dnn and the
original space which has a lot of
complications past
we can see that it trains
this takes some time because there's a
lot of initializations that happening
and distributed computing that happens
but you can see that two now two trials
and this is the dynamically added space
where you can see the mean square error
keeps on reducing
right you can also see the current
simulation of parameters
right from all the parameters that we
had passed there is one value which is
chosen from each of those parameters and
the current model that is being run is
being run on those parameters
i've just used number of samples too but
ideally it should be more than 50 or 60
models because
it increases proportionately to your
hyper-parameter search space so for
example if you have 10 variables with
two variations each there's
10 to the power 2 combinations that's
that's going to happen
so in that particular case the number of
trials the number of samples you have to
add should be at least 50 or 60 because
the bayesian optimization will not work
like a grid search where you have to
keep training on all the different
combinations but the bayesian will
definitely optimize towards improving
okay so two samples trained quickly and
i have this
best config
no batch normalization layer batch size
16 epochs 15 learning rate e power minus
five glory uniform zeros and the entire
dictionary that you guys can see
again making a prediction just like we
did for stacked networks works
seamlessly by passing a list of
individual inputs any questions
you can also set the verbose to a
larger number so you'll get a lot more
detail about every model that's tuning
how it's improving how it's not
okay
working with pre-trained models that's
the last topic for today
so pre-trained models obviously have
been trained with the imagenet data set
large data sets huge performances right
and the only thing we need to do with
pre-trained models is to add a line
which says set trainable false
right so i'll just quickly show you the
code for that
[Music]
i did not bother to make this code
completely on my own because there was a
good uh
article online
i'm going to add a link to that article
pretty soon
right so from the keras applications we
get the dense net we get the resnet
we use concatenate all the things that
we talked about the fundamental
additions
we create our input shape use the input
layer the input layer actually helps
setting a default input size
so if you want to set a default input
size for all the images that you're
going to use you can use the input layer
to make sure you first build the network
and then worry about how you're going to
pass your data through the network
because in a lot of these cases the
handling of different data sets is the
larger problem the network as you can
see is fairly simple to build and train
and parameter tune
so this is where i'm building the resnet
i just include one key factor which is
include top is equal to false which is
the final layer of the pre-trained
resnet
i do the same for dense net
i use the same set of weights by the way
so that these models are not trained on
different data sets not learn to detect
different kinds of features
and again include top equals false
now here i can actually do
customization
right
what do i mean by customization suppose
you do not want the resnet to be trained
at all
but you still want some amount of
training on densenet
or let's say you have a pre-trained
model and your own stacked model
suppose for the housing data set if i
would have used the resnet or the
densenet so the resnet and densenet i
don't want to train on them i don't want
those convolutional networks to be
trained because they're pretty well
trained but my numerical dnn or my
categorical dna i would definitely want
to train on that so i can actually use a
pre-trained model
not further train it
except just include the last layer which
is specific to imagenet
and then concatenate them with the
models that i have made so i can
actually use the powers of
the imagenet large dataset as well as
use it for my particular use case by
concatenation the idea again is pretty
simple the concatenate layer
functional api of tensorflow to get
access to the combined input
finally building a layer of my own i
made it 10 nodes considering the mnist
data set you can choose the number of
nodes in the final layer depending on
what your output is
and finally i create the model and i
look at the model summary
you can see resnet50 version 2 densenet
121
okay there's a lot of parameters
involved but i can definitely choose to
not train certain parameters not train
certain layers as well
and
completely not train a neural network
that is a part of it
okay
so
that brings me to the end of my tutorial
if there are any questions i welcome
them
okay cool then thank you so much
[Applause]
yes
your experience you give this type of
beverage to
so honestly i've not used it with the
with spark so i'll not be able to
comment but one of my friends did with
pi spark and hyperopt
and he told me that with aws and gcp
there's certain kind of complications
that happen when with pi spark and
hyperop but with their latest version of
hyperopt i think they fixed it so it
will not create a lot of difference
raytune is largely beneficial because
there's a lot of
content available online with respect to
model training uh in a parallel system
with raytune so tensorboard integrations
and all of those things they work really
well with raytune for pi spark you will
have to write additional code and
functions to make sure it matches the
idea
okay
have a good day thanks everyone